Q learning is named
after the Q function.
What is that?
Well, let's dig in and find out.
Q can be written as a function, so
we might have parentheses around s and
a, or you can think of it as a table.
So in this class we're
going to view Q as a table.
And it's got two dimensions, s and a.
So s is the state that we're looking at,
and a is the action we might take.
Q represents the value of taking action
a in state s, and
there's two components to that.
The two components are the immediate
reward that you get for
taking action a in state s,
plus the discounted reward.
And what that is about,
what the discounted reward is about,
is the reward you get for
future actions.
So an important thing to know
is that Q is not greedy,
in the sense that it just represents
the reward you get for acting now.
It also represents the reward you
get for acting in the future.
Let's suppose we have Q
already created for us.
We have this table.
How can we use it to
figure out what to do?
So what we do in any particular
state is the policy.
And we represent the policy with pi.
So pi of s means, what is the action
we take when we are in state s,
or what is the policy for state s?
And we take advantage of our
Q table to figure that out.
Here's how it works.
We're in state s and we want to
find out which action is the best.
Well, all we need to do is look
across all the potential actions and
find out which value of
(Q [s,a]) is maximized.
So we don't change s, we just
step through each value of a, and
the one that is the largest
is the action we should take.
And the mathematical way to represent
this is to use the function argmax,
so argmax of a of this function.
So what that does is it finds
the a that maximizes this, and
then the answer is a.
After we run Q learning for long enough,
we will eventually converge
to the optimal policy.
And we represent that
with a little star.
So the optimal policy is pi star of s.
[COUGH] And similarly the optimal
Q table is Q star [s, a].
Now this is how to use
a Q table if you have it.
We need now to consider how do we
build that Q table in the first place.